we continue our series the road to 2020
this morning where we talked to current
and prospective candidates about
important issues that affect the country
John Hickenlooper is a former two-term
governor of Colorado during his time in
office he expanded Colorado's Medicaid
coverage fought for new gun laws and
developed the innovative career-wise
training program to help high school
students get apprenticeships
Hickenlooper is one of 14 candidates
actively seeking the Democratic
nomination in 2020 and he's joining us
at the table governor good to have you
morning I want to talk to you about but
let's start in Afghanistan the news of
death of two servicemen that makes it a
four this year alone do you support the
president's plan of negotiating with the
Taliban even if that means excluding the
elected Afghan government well I think
we've got to get the elected Afghan
government involved as soon as possible
but certainly a war that's been going on
for seven seventeen years and that we
see no indication of victory you've got
to look at it you've got to look at
different routes and different solutions
and one of those is cutting back now the
progress we've made in Afghanistan in
terms of women in schools all kinds of
major changes for the for the good we
should try to protect them where we can
but ultimately we need to remove our
active military troops from that as soon
as possible like the president would
like I'm not just as soon as possible
gives away I would go about it that way
because it gives away our hand but it
limits our choices which sort of
timetable do you think I think the
sooner the better that's a slightly
softer language than saying ASAP but I
think that there's room for negotiation
there to make sure that we protect think
of all the people that are in
Afghanistan that have been our allies
been giving us intelligence I mean we
need to make sure that that we don't
jeopardize a lot of those relationships
you've talked about a crisis of division
in this country as a president how would
you heal that well I think that's that's
why I'm running for president is we are
in the middle of a national crisis of
division and I look at what we've done
in Colorado where you know in terms of
we're almost universal health care we
did in a bipartisan way we were able to
get the oil and gas industry is sit down
with your bar metal community and
address methane regulations the first
comprehensive methane regulations in the
country
and that kind of outcome-based you know
progress really progressive achievement
is something that the country I think
needs and there's an appetite for not
people just waving their arms and
jumping around but an appetite for
people actually getting things done
would you consider a Republican vice
president I've heard you say you would
consider a woman would you consider a
Republican vice president you know I
don't I don't think that would work
and it certainly in this election I'm a
great believer once the election is over
I try to hire the most talented people I
can find from all different backgrounds
all different parts of the country and
certainly Republicans and Democrats but
if you had a Republican as a vice
president candidate that would alienate
so many Democrats would really diminish
your chances of victory you generated
some confusion when you were asked that
question by Dana Bash this week when you
were asked if you would put a woman on
the ticket and instead of just saying
yes or no you asked the question well
why isn't a woman being asked if she'd
put a male on the ticket what did you
mean by well I said I said yes I said
sure and then I said but I and what I
was trying to say however inartfully I
was trying to say that that the question
itself in some way discounts the
probability that woman will actually get
the nomination and this is such a
diverse and powerful field of candidates
it's one of the reasons I'm proud to be
a Democrat governor I want to ask you I
was talking to one of my fellow
Millennials yesterday and I said
governor Hickenlooper is gonna be on the
show he said oh yeah he was governor
when Pop became legal and he's a guy who
believes in the science behind climate
change and it made me think how do you
punch through in a crowded field you
know I had the name recognition of a lot
of the other folks so how do you rise to
the top I think when you look at
everybody I'm the one person that has
actually been out there I was a an
entrepreneur build a business from
scratch I put a team together I was
mayor for eight years and you know buy
any record we achieved we made real
progress with the city of Denver took it
from no kind of a flyover city to a to a
major emerging city and then as governor
we've really created progressive
achievement again and again I think
there is that appetite for people that
when when I got elected governor we were
40th in job creation
now we're the number one economy in the
country for the last two years according
to US News and World Report we've made
all these all this progress and
especially with Millennials when you sit
down and say here
what I can do here's we've reduced
teenage pregnancy in Colorado by 60% in
the last eight years these are the kinds
of achievements that most milania's care
about here's how we're going to create
you know opportunities and education for
everybody can we talk about the shooting
in New Zealand because just six days
after the deadliest mass shooting
they are already moving to change the
laws with little resistance there when
you look at that do you think we need to
take notes or do is there something we
can learn for that from that or do you
think that's how they do it but that's
not how we operate here or do we need to
know I think everyone should be paying
attention to how quickly they're moving
forward and when we did when we took on
the NRA back in 2013 after the shooting
in the Aurora movie is you know in the
end the NRA no matter what we said we
couldn't get them to go along with the
universal background checks even when we
pulled that to statistics it showed that
in the previous year getting to just
half the gun purchases I mean there were
I mean it was amazing there are 38
people convicted of homicide who trying
to buy a gun and we stopped them overall
over 3,000 violent criminals who tried
to buy a gun and we stopped them and yet
still we couldn't get a single
Republican to support that that
initiative would gun control be a top
priority for your administration yeah I
think we would go immediately you start
state-by-state but it should be a
national effort and ultimately a
national victory in terms of universal
background checks high-capacity
magazines these are things that don't
take away and we don't want to take away
people's guns and we're not trying to
you know diminish the Second Amendment
but we've got to make sure that we keep
guns out of the hands of dangerous you
talk about being a proud entrepreneur
why can't you just say you're a
capitalist full-stop you know it's funny
it's a little bit like a friend asked
well where you going in high school well
you know that's not the first label I
choose yeah but be hard to argue it you
know alright you're gonna put me into a
category I am a capitalist I started 20
businesses like the knobs governor
Hickenlooper his apologies we've got to
leave it there but thanks